[Music]
Harry Potter fans are an extremely
observant and dedicated Bunch and they
do not like to be left hanging when it
comes to their favorite storylines watch
until number one to see how a wizard's
education presents a serious plot hole
if this is your first time visiting this
channel don't forget to subscribe to the
things and please give this video a big
thumbs up here are 10 potholes in Harry
Potter that left fans hanging Perry's
glasses
unlike many magical and fantastical
characters The Wizard of Harry Potter do
not have any exceptional qualities when
it comes to their appearance quite the
opposite in fact one tumblr user made a
great observation that earns him over
110,000 notes and reblogs he questioned
why no one ever took advantage of
Harry's shortsightedness and disarmed
him by simply removing his glasses we're
wondering if spells and potions caused
Wizards to forget about more traditional
forms of disarmament or bullying even
with the use of magic
neither Draco nor Voldemort ever
utilized the akio glasses spell in a
core article yinshuang ho even prints
out that while Madame Pomfrey can heal
the bones and harry's broken arm his
eyesight is never corrected however in
an interview JK Rowling explained that
the decision to give Harry glasses was
because she herself for glasses as a
child tired of only reading about
secondary nerdy characters with glasses
it was important for Rowling to create a
hero with glasses something she hadn't
encountered in books she read there's a
symbolic explanation too as we read the
books from this point of view literally
looking through his eyes though glasses
don't seem to line up with some plot
points the reasons behind them gives us
enough reason to look past them
time-turner troubles as anyone who
enjoys fantasy or science fiction will
know time-travel is not a simple concept
instead traveling in time alters
timelines thus changing lives and events
for anyone with any involvement in the
original chronology already confused
then it's easy to have sympathy for JK
Rowling who encountered complications
when she introduced the concept of time
travel with time Turner's in Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban if
going back in time was possible in the
during World how then would rolling be
able to justify any of the plot points
as it would be feasible for a brave
wizard to travel back in time and undo
any catastrophe Rowland admits to not
having fully considered the
ramifications of introducing time travel
but did her best to ensure lu sims were
tied by having Hermione and Dumbledore
explained the severity of the
consequences entailed in traveling
through time she also made sure that
Hermione returned the only time Turner
Hogwarts had as well as eliminating the
chance that any time could be revisited
by destroying all the time Turner's at
the ministry do you think JK Rowling did
enough to solve this plot hole or should
she have gone back in time to think it
through a bit more thoroughly
how does Sirius get his wand back when a
prisoner checks into Azkaban they are
required to turn their wands just like
muggles are required to turn in their
possessions further this helps to ensure
that they won't be casting spells while
incarcerated having wands would also
undermine the Dementors ability to guard
the prison yet when Sirius Black escapes
from Azkaban in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban he manages to
recover his wand this detail is never
explained in the book but that hasn't
stopped fans from speculating about how
serious got his wand one Harry Potter
fanatic Francisco Xavier begorrah
Navarro suggests that one explanation
could be that the ministry had actually
kept Sirius Black's wand on his behalf
or purchased one from Ollivander this is
not out of the realm of possibility as
some of the members of the ministry were
also in the order of the Phoenix and may
have planned on aiding Sirius in his
escape alternatively it could have been
a black family heirloom that Sirius
retrieved from his parents immediately
after he's escaped nevertheless the
details of how serious got his blond
back are never addressed in the book or
movie do you have any theories of how
serious got his wand back let us know in
the comments Ministry of Magic is
selective in their reprimands the
Ministry of Magic declares that under
age magic is prohibited
however they're inconsistent in
following up on situations when minors
cast spells in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows breeders are introduced
to the trace a spell used by the
ministry to ensure that no one under the
age of 17 is casting spells yet the use
of the trace in the books is
inconsistent manique set the Swan
speculates about these irregularities in
a post on Stack Exchange though the
trace catches the hover charm window be
casted at the Dursleys home on privet
drive the ministry is unable to
determine whether Dobby or Harry is
responsible for casting the spell
however when author Weasley pays the
Dursleys a visit he uses magic to invade
the teacups thrown at him and return
Dudley's tongue to its normal size the
trace does not detect it even Dumbledore
uses magic at the Dursleys
and Harry Potter and the half-blood
Prince but Harry is never accused the
only accurately detected underage magic
is when Harry blows up his aunt and when
he casts a Petronius the trace does not
work in magical homes either making it
less effective and making sure underaged
wizards aren't using magic Farida serum
in court verita serum is a carefully
controlled potion whose purpose serves
to force the person under its influence
to exclusively tell the truth as its the
Wizards equivalent of a lie detector
it's lack of use in the courtroom is a
confusing plot hole Harry Potter uses
magic when he conjures the Patronus
charm in the muggle world which leads
the ministry to hold a trial to
determine if Harry should be expelled
from Hogwarts the ministry's official
statement denied the return of Alda Mort
which Harry Potter consistently
contradicted the ministry's biased
against Harry explains why they would be
reluctant to use the verita serum as
truth might not have been in the
ministry's best interest however it
would have been an easy way for Harry to
defend his innocence in using magic only
as defense a useful implementation of
verita serum could have been useful in
Barty Crouch his trial that Harry
witnesses through the Kim Steve and
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire why
would the verita serum not have been
used to determine a serious case such as
this one when Barty Crouch reveals the
names of Death Eaters it would have been
much easier to determine whether or not
these individuals were actually guilty
rather than just trusting a known
criminal wizard economy is nonsense
it seems almost counterintuitive that
Wizards would require any type of
currency when magic is at their disposal
however gold is frequently mentioned as
a means of exchange when paying close
attention it seems that the economics of
Harry Potter just don't quite make sense
for example a song by Harry and the
Potters highlights that while a single
unicorn hair cost ten galleons
a wand purchased at Ollivanders can cost
only seven galleons even though some
contain unicorn hair this means the sell
actually costs Ollivander money this is
just one detail and an even larger plot
hole if magic grants you anything you
need why would anyone work even more
confusing as Megan McArdle points out in
an article from the Guardian is how the
Weasleys end up being so poor while
problems could be solved by a house-elf
or a useful spell the Weasleys
inexplicably have trouble affording new
clothes and schoolbooks a fan post on
Stack Exchange speculates about the
broomsticks and wands that are sold
their origins go unexplained the entire
economic functioning of Diagon Alley is
falled if we take into consideration
that the amount of wizards that graduate
from Hogwarts each year would outnumber
the available amount of wizard jobs
thestrals too soon to see them up until
the order of the Phoenix Harry and fans
alike believe that Hogwarts carriages
were drawn by magic however it was
revealed at the beginning of the novel
that the carriages are actually pulled
by thestrals Luna Lovegood explains how
festivals can only be perceived after
someone has witnessed a death fans
notice a pothole as a carriage
transported Harry to Hogsmeade at the
end of the Goblet of Fire
Harry was unable to see any festivals at
the end of the Triwizard Tournament even
though he had just witnessed Cedric
Diggory death in an interview at the
Edinburgh Book Festival
JK Rowling addressed this strange
inconsistency first of all Harry had
been present for the murder of his
parents technically he should have
always been able to see the fest rules
except that Rowling claims that Harry
was too young to process what he had
seen asked for subjects death Rowling
had two explanations for Harry's
inability to perceive the Destro's at
the end of the book
firstly Harry would have been in a state
of shock so his brain would not have
processed that he witnessed the death
secondly Rowling wanted to reserved the
explanation of the fest rules for the
order of the Phoenix as a way to set a
darker tone the missing day an extremely
dedicated an attentive group of Harry
Potter fans have discovered an
incredibly confusing pothole Harry
Potter's parents Lily and James Potter
were murdered by Voldemort October 31st
1981 Hagrid rescues the 15 month old boy
who lived that same day but they only
appear on privet Drive before midnight
the next day November 1st this begs the
question where were Hagrid and Harry for
24 hours Professor McGonagall disguised
as the cat waited by privet drive all
day Dumbledore also tells Hagrid that he
is late but nothing is explained even
more confusing is the fact that Hagrid
who transported baby Harry by flying
motorcycle state said they had no issue
with their travel and that you managed
to get Harry out of the wreckage before
any muggles came to investigate the
scene a final contradiction is the fact
that Hagrid only had to bring Harry from
Southwest to Surrey a journey which
wouldn't take them anywhere in near 24
hours even if they weren't travelling by
flying motorbike do you have any
theories about why there's a full day
missing between the Potters death and
Harry's delivery to privet drive let us
know Peter Pettigrew is immune to the
moroder's map no one would ever suspect
a pet of being an undercover
backstabbing wizard yet that's exactly
what Scabbers was revealed to be it was
originally a reddit user who pointed out
this unanswered plot point
Fred and George managed to still filches
moroder's map during Harry's first year
four years later in Prisoner of Azkaban
they gifted to Harry a fans post on
science fiction and fantasy Stack
Exchange even pointed out how Scabbers
originally belonged to Percy technically
this means that Peter Pettigrew's name
should have shown up on the map for four
years
however the Weasley twins never
questioned or confronted Percy or Ron
about that fact that someone named Peter
was often right next to them even
sleeping in the same bed at night
it seems strange that the name Peter
never even came up in conversation poor
wife Fred and George didn't think it was
strange when Peter didn't show up in the
Great Hall during meals
he would have often appeared next to Ron
if they consulted the moroder's math
there's even proof that Peter did show
up on the math and wasn't just conjuring
a charm to prevent anyone from knowing
his whereabouts
Lupin uses the marauders map to discover
Peter and Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban school subjects for many 10
year-olds turning 11 held the faint hope
that a letter from Hogwarts might
actually appear in the mail as amazing
as this school admission would seem to
any child who grew up reading or
watching Harry Potter when examined
closely the school's hold premise is a
bit shaky first of all it's difficult to
determine what goes into making a
powerful wizard based on the fact that
most spells consist of one or two words
and that hermione is no more powerful
than Harry
it seems that academics doesn't
necessary factor into a Wizards ability
to perform magic this begs the question
other than Wizarding theory
what do Harry Potter and his peers learn
at school they definitely aren't
learning traditional school subjects
like math literature or geography
this is particularly strange as many
wizards end up living their lives among
muggles and would need to learn the
necessary skills to prevent from drawing
attention though muggles study is an
elective it's impossible that it would
encompass all the subjects muggles would
know even if they remain in the
Wizarding World how would these young
wizards acquire any type of job skills
did we miss any potholes or theories let
us know in the comments and that's all
for the ten thought holes in Harry
Potter that left fans hangings make sure
to like this video and subscribe to the
things to catch more videos like this
thanks for watching
[Music]